what are the defining characteristics
what are the interesting things about xi
jinping the president of china
as a leader on the world stage
his father was a
early
leader he was himself
[Music]
in the cultural revolution at times
treated
brutally
um and during that period of time it was
very very difficult
and he came up
you know through the ranks and he's a
very
intelligent man
um
when he first came to power they as you
know they have two five-year terms
and we're now coming to the end of the
second of those five-year terms when he
first came to power um
he felt that there should be a lot of
reform
and reform meant
moving to much more of a market an open
economy
when
that happened in him coming in
i had some contact with
economic policymakers but and the
circumstances then were that five major
banks
lent to state-owned enterprises and
local governments with implied
government guarantees
and so there was not control of that and
they and the movement to aim more of a
market economy and the development of
markets uh was a primary and also the
dealing with the corruption issue there
was a lot of corruption
prior to that and that was viewed as an
existential threat to the system so that
became the primary objective
and then as time progressed
over those 10 years there was a
a lot of changing
in the world finance their financial
circumstances opening many many other
markets
they particularly getting money to small
and medium-sized enterprises and
developing a lending system and then
establishing controls on it so right now
there's
a vibrant
capital markets
you can raise capital you can be an
entrepreneur you can become a
billionaire
in the capital markets and they develop
the markets to be the second largest
capital markets
at the same time
they had to deal with their
rising debt issue
which they began to deal with
really about four years ago
when the second
term
began and the um
and then uh lu ha became um
the vice premier um responsible for that
and to um and deal with uh those issues
so you see right now that what's
happening is uh the dealing with the
real estate bubble there was a
development in real estate a bubble
which produced
a lot of unproductive lending
and xi ping said
you know um
houses are meant to live in not to
speculate on and so that was wasteful so
they established what they call three
red lines which are financial ratios
that the property developers had to live
within and that is then causing the
adjustments that are going on now which
in my view are very healthy because um
whenever there's bankruptcies and so on
the most in the public think okay that's
a problem it's in many cases really a
cleaning up of bad debts and bad
practices and so um that's what's going
on so that's let's say economically at
the same time there is the changing
relationships the changing world order
the changing relationships with the
united states and other countries
which is becoming
much less cooperative and much more
war-like much more confrontational
um those two things the
the domestic debt problem and domestic
has led to
um what's called core what they call
core leadership which means um a
leadership more around him that um is
less
challenging
because they believe in history that
during very difficult times
um a more centrally controlled
decision-making process lends itself
better than to a more fragmented
political contentious project and that's
basically what's um going on now
you said it very eloquently
but you mean
the leadership is surrounded by yes men
and there's a lot of
centralized control
that characterization
is view is much more black and white
than it really is
uh but it leans towards that direction
they're like for example of the standing
members of the polar bureau four are
more eligi uh allowed him um three or
less so
you have to understand that it's kind of
a collective leadership at the top and
then of course there's just jockeying
for power um you know in a highly
political sense
at the top
but no one leader can be successful
against
the uh all those powers at the top so
it's very politically negotiating it's
you know it's very much more like if you
put
um in the united states the democrats
and the republicans and they had to be
in the same government and they work it
out uh it's kind of something like that
and then so that's that struggle but
it's an internal struggle
you